[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please give a warm
Google welcome to Phil Keoghan.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
CINDY HALVORSEN: Oh.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I wore
the same watch today.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Oh, nice.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah,
the lucky watch
that was there at the
finish line for you guys.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That
is a lucky watch.
Great.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us today.
We're really excited to
have you in our office.
We got to be in your office
for three weeks as we filmed,
and now you're in our office.
PHIL KEOGHAN: So is
everybody called Googlers?
Is that what you call everybody?
Well, thanks for having me.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So for those
of us who have maybe not seen
the show and just
pretend to see the show,
can you do a quick recap
of how the show works?
PHIL KEOGHAN: So the show's now
been going 17 years, for those
of you who haven't seen it.
And 29 seasons, we just went
to air with the 29th season.
And essentially, the
idea is that normally we
have 11 teams of two in
preexisting relationships--
grandparents, best
friends, husband
and wife, engaged
couples, brother/sister.
Whatever that
combination is there
in a preexisting
relationship, and then they
race around the world
following a series of clues
from country to country.
The slower races get
eliminated along the way
until we end up with the fastest
three, fastest three teams.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Or
the luckiest three.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Or
sometimes we've actually
had four teams run
in the last leg.
And then they race to the finish
line to win that $1 million
prize.
This season we just
changed things up to--
that's just to mess
up my explanation
about how this all works.
Normally it's 11 teams of two
people who know each other.
This season what
we decided to do
was take 22 complete
strangers and pair them up
at the starting line
so they literally
didn't know each other's names.
And that's proved to be
a little interesting.
You've seen the season so far?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Of course!
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, no,
I just wanted to check.
I thought maybe after you won,
you thought, all right, we won,
we're out of here.
We're going to watch
something else.
Now it's "The Voice" we're
going to watch or something
like that.
CINDY HALVORSEN: We
do watch that too.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, you do?
That's good.
CINDY HALVORSEN: How did
the dynamics of strangers
being on "The Race" together
change the storytelling
process?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, you know--
let's put that down there.
Normally, when you're in an
existing relationship, if you--
there's sort of
no filter, right,
when you're with somebody
in an existing relationship.
And sometimes people just--
they bicker at each other,
let's be honest, you know.
And sometimes that
makes for good TV.
And sometimes you're
more polite to people
that you might meet as a
stranger in a supermarket
than you are
sometimes to somebody
you're apparently meant to love.
And so at the starting
line, everybody
was very polite to
each other because they
didn't know each
other's names, they
didn't know where
they came from.
And suddenly they found
themselves paired up
with a complete stranger.
And one of the first
things-- after I
said go, one of the first
things that happened was it's
like, oh, hi, I'm Phil.
What's your name,
and where do you
come from, and all
that sort of stuff?
But the show is shot
12 shows in 21 days.
And it's a pressure
cooker, as you know.
And so it took about
80 hours before it
went from being polite to
strangers or the stranger
that you were with to no filter.
Listen, dude.
This is a team.
I don't know how you
operate ordinarily,
but I will not be
spoken to like that.
You will pull your head in, and
I'm as much a part of this team
as you are, and so we
need to work together.
And some of the people
that have been paired up
are people that you would
just normally not-- like,
they would not normally choose
to be with a person like that.
This is like the
unwanted relative
that you have to
have at Thanksgiving
who says all those
obnoxious things
and spills food all
over themselves.
And the only reason that you
have to get together with them
is because they're family
and it's Thanksgiving.
So some of the pairings work.
Some of the pairings don't work.
And the end result is we
end up with a great show.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That's great.
That's--
PHIL KEOGHAN: Makes
for entertaining TV.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So
over the 29 seasons
you've raced a
million 68,000 miles.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I
did not know that.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah, I just
did the math for you today.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Wow, I love that.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So Google Maps
obviously covers the world.
How do you think Google Maps
plays into "The Amazing Race"?
PHIL KEOGHAN:
Well, Google Maps--
I mean, I'm a huge, huge fan.
I have a great story about that.
When we talk about my film and
how I used Google in general,
just the technology.
But think about
how much technology
has changed since "The Amazing
Race" first went to air.
You know, we had our
first show in 2001.
And you could travel the
world and you could hide away
in countries and people
wouldn't know where you were.
And now people are
like live broadcasting
us running through the airport.
And that's just crazy, right?
I mean, it's like people
have their own broadcasting
capabilities.
And people can
obviously use Google.
If they get access
to a computer,
they can look up certain things.
And I do believe that that
might have been something
you might have
done in your time,
look up a few things in Google?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yes, actually.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah?
Tell the story.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So we have
a few points in our race
where we definitely used Google
Maps to get us from point A
to point B. The one
time we didn't, we
used this random Dutch web site.
We got super lost,
and we lost the cars.
We went from first
place to third place
and lost those cars.
Bummer.
But it actually helped
us in the very final leg
that you saw here.
This is-- we raced
six years ago.
The four--
PHIL KEOGHAN: Has
it been that long?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah,
it was that long.
PHIL KEOGHAN: And you've had
two children since then, right?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah.
We have had two.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Time flies.
CINDY HALVORSEN: I know.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I was in my 30s
when we started this show.
Now-- now I'm--
CINDY HALVORSEN: Now you're 35.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Now
I'm not in my 30s.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm a little older.
And you've got two kids.
How'd that happen?
CINDY HALVORSEN: I know.
Yeah, so it was the
age of flip phones.
And so we texted Google the
clue to the final pit stop,
and it texted us the answer.
It was awesome.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Don't
you love that?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yep.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yay for Google.
Is that why you ended
up working here,
because you figured
you've got to give back?
Got to give back?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah.
I think it helped us win.
PHIL KEOGHAN: This is your debt?
It worked out.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Now I
give my service to Google.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah,
no, I'm a big fan.
And in this film that
I shot, I reached
out to Google and Google
Maps, and hugely helpful.
I mean, it's just changed the
way that we see the world.
Because I love maps.
I really love tactile maps.
I love putting them up
on the wall and looking.
But there's
something amazing now
just about being able to
drop in and really explore
a place before you get there.
And it's sort of the trip before
the trip that you can now take.
Also just writing the
scripts for "Amazing Race,"
I'm constantly on Google to
look up fascinating facts
and figures--
real facts, not false facts--
to put into the show.
You know, the audience
love the little facts
that we give along the way.
So I'm always looking for
the really interesting ones,
like how many thousand islands
there are in Indonesia.
And people are always
surprised by that.
And fascinating facts
about the deepest lakes
and all those sort of stuff.
So I like it.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That's great.
That's great.
So take us actually to
the production room.
So there's lots of
conversation that
happens before you plot out the
show and actually go and film.
Take us to the table where
you're having conversation
with Bertram, Elise,
whoever else is in the room.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, yeah,
I mean, Bertram and Elise,
you know, they work
with a fantastic team.
And Bertram takes the
first hand at sketching out
where he wants to go.
And then from there,
everybody supports him
and looking for great
stories and great ideas.
Supported by a really
great group of people.
And what's good about the show
now being on as long as it has,
a lot of people have
come to us inviting us
to come to their countries too.
And then ultimately,
CBS is the one
that signs off on
not only where we go
but who we have on the show.
So Les Moonves still has--
Les Moonves, for those of
you who don't know, runs--
I mean, the guy is
very successful.
But he really does take
a hand on everybody
who goes on "The Race."
And then ultimately CBS signs
off on the route that we go to.
Do you say "root" or
"rowt" in America?
"Rowt"?
CINDY HALVORSEN:
"Tomayto," "tomahto."
Probably both.
PHIL KEOGHAN:
"Tomayto," "tomahto."
What would you say,
"root" or "rowt"?
AUDIENCE: "Rowt."
PHIL KEOGHAN: "Rowt."
So Les Moonves signs
off on the "rowt"--
[LAUGHTER]
--that we take.
And then from there, we've been
to some just incredible places.
And what I love about our show
is, unlike a stage show or so
many shows that
are on television,
the background is
always different.
You know, you never
see the same background
twice on "Amazing Race."
It's harder, I think,
for other shows,
whether they're staged
shows like, you know,
a singing competition show.
I think it's harder for
them to stay fresh season
after season just because--
one of the things-- just
because the stage is the same.
They can change the lighting
and do a few things there,
but we have the ability
to really radically change
the look of the show,
not only by where they go
but what they do.
And of course,
like all shows, we
change the people who
come on every season.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So let's talk
about the different locations.
You had mentioned it's like
traveling before you travel,
right?
When you're--
PHIL KEOGHAN: With the
research, you mean?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yes,
with the research.
So talk about in today's
political climate,
where people maybe don't
feel as comfortable
traveling the world.
How does "Amazing Race"
play in that conversation?
PHIL KEOGHAN: That's a
really good question.
A lot of people assume
that America is the safest
country in the world.
America is a very safe country.
It's not the safest
country in the world.
And so then you ask people,
well, where does America rate?
You guys can Google
it right now.
Where does America rate in
terms of being the safest
country in the world?
And it's way further down
than a lot of people realize.
Now we'd all agree that
America is a safe country.
So if America is
as safe as it is--
and it's not even
in the top 10--
then, gosh, there's
a lot of safe places
to travel to in the world.
The reason that a lot of
people who haven't traveled,
which is why I
really love stressing
the importance of travel,
particularly for young people,
is that their
perception of the world
is that wherever you go
in the world something
is going to be going wrong.
Because when they see
the rest of the world
normally, in network primetime
television or on the news,
something is going wrong because
of that old news adage, which
is, if it bleeds, it leads.
So generally
speaking, if somebody
sees something
about Spain, they'll
see when there's been a riot or
there's been some big protest
or something has gone wrong.
And so people, if they start
to hear that over and over
and over and over
again, they just assume,
why would I want
to get on a plane
and leave this safe country of
mine, this safe neighborhood,
this safe state that I
live in and go to a place
where things are going wrong?
So what we get to
do is to juxtapose
that with, hey, look at
all these safe places
you can travel to in the world.
Look at all these
amazing people.
Look at all these wonderful
things you can do.
So we really are the antithesis
of what the news is doing.
We are celebrating
what's right in the world
as opposed to amplifying
and playing up
and selling what's wrong.
So I think it is
hugely important.
And you know, just seeing
different cultures,
seeing the ways that different
people live around the world,
it's important for all of us
to be exposed to that, I think.
And so our show,
network primetime show,
millions of people,
literally, watching.
You know, appointment viewing.
I love being involved in
something that, again, there's
enough of the celebration
of what's wrong.
I love that our show really
does focus on, all right,
we're going to show you
something really cool
that maybe you
haven't seen before.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That's great.
So similarly, let's talk about--
at Google, we believe
a diverse team
can lead to better results.
Let's talk about the diversity
that you've shown on "The Race"
in terms of the cast and what
qualities of these diverse cast
members make a better team.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well,
diversity is key.
And I mean, I come
from New Zealand.
One of the reasons I came to
America is I saw it as a place
where you could make
anything happen.
And coming from New
Zealand and growing up,
what you read about America
is it's always sold and taught
as the land of opportunity.
And this is a country
of immigrants.
This is a country
where people came
from all corners of the world to
find a better life in America.
And that's why I
like living here.
I love my country, New Zealand.
But the opportunities
that are here far
exceed what is available
in New Zealand.
And so I also feel like
in America there's always
been a celebration of success.
And that success has come
from such a myriad of people.
We have prided ourselves in
always casting a diverse cast
to represent the plethora
of the American people.
If you remember the
Guidos in season 1
where they were openly
affectionate with each other
as a gay couple.
That was in 2001.
It was kind of radical.
People weren't that comfortable
with seeing that sort of thing
on television.
So we are trying to perpetuate
the idea of acceptance
and difference and
that with difference
comes a more
interesting country.
And so if ever there was a
time to celebrate difference
and to focus on the fact
that difference is good
and diversity is
good, it's right now.
Because if we
polarize-- if we start
getting more and more
polarized, we will get division.
There's misunderstanding
that comes from all of that.
So I obviously-- I don't
know this for a fact,
and I don't want to
give a false fact--
but I would venture
to say that--
nobody wants to do that.
I don't want to do fake
news or anything like that.
But I would venture
to say that we've
had probably the most diverse
cast of any reality show.
If you think about it, even if
you look at all the competition
shows, they're all
singers who are diverse.
They're all designers
who are diverse.
They all do one particular
thing and they're diverse.
They dance and they're diverse.
Or they're celebrities
and they dance.
Or whatever the show is.
But we have a cast,
particularly this season
with 22 individuals.
They are black, they're white,
they're tall, they're short,
they're fit, they're unfit.
Rich, poor, Democrats,
Republicans.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Limbs, no limbs.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Limbs-- exactly.
Some people-- we've had amputee.
Remember we had Sarah, who's
an unbelievable athlete.
We had Luke, who was deaf.
We've tried to have as much
diversity as we possibly can.
At the end of the
day, we're still
casting interesting people.
We have to have
interesting people.
But I feel like the net
that we can throw out
to find interesting people
is a much bigger net than,
oh, we're going to throw
a net out but, by the way,
you all have to
sing really well.
You know, we're not
about that at all.
These people come in and, trust
me, some of them cannot sing.
They cannot dance.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That's me.
And me.
PHIL KEOGHAN: They come into it.
And do you remember Dandrew?
Do you remember that
when they were in Russia
and he was trying to march?
For any of you who remember that
season in Russia, and he was--
[COUGHING] excuse
me-- trying to march
and he just could not do it.
And you know people
who don't know
that they don't have rhythm.
They're worse than anything
because they are adamant that
they're in step, but they're--
no, oh, it was hysterical.
So diversity is a
big part of, I think,
what has made our show work.
Because people at home identify
with somebody on the cast.
There's somebody there
that is their uncle
or they feel like
they see themselves
emulated in that person so.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Awesome.
Well, you've also
had many YouTubers.
We have one here today who's
going to be visiting us.
You've had many
YouTubers on the cast.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, we
had a season of YouTubers.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yes.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Right?
And what we were
trying to do there was,
again, just embrace the fact
that the world has changed
so much, the way that
people communicate,
the fact that Tyler Oakley
can reach as many people as he
had or--
the idea that anybody
now can find a platform
to be able to share
something that they do.
Maybe they're amazing at
embroidery and they have--
there's a guy online
who ties flies.
And I think he has, like,
a million followers.
And he literally sits
and tells people how--
flies that you make for
fishing, fly fishing?
He literally is-- his--
yeah, I guess I didn't--
[LAUGHTER]
CINDY HALVORSEN: I thought you
were talking about flies flies.
PHIL KEOGHAN: He ties flies.
Oh, yeah, no, no.
Flies flies.
Although some guys do use
live flies on their flies.
Did you know that?
No, it's true.
CINDY HALVORSEN: I know
nothing about fishing.
PHIL KEOGHAN: No, they've tied
live flies on their flies.
Because they look like--
I mean, because they
are flies, and then
they put it on
the hook, and then
the fish sees the
real fly, and then
the fish eats that live fly.
And the live fly is on a fly.
And then that fly gets the fish.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Excellent.
PHIL KEOGHAN: You
think I'm kidding.
I'm not.
Anyway--
CINDY HALVORSEN: I
kind of follow you.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I'm just saying
that anybody can do anything,
and they can be online.
And so we wanted
to embrace that.
And so we tried it,
and it was interesting.
I think, you know, we
also thought, well,
maybe those people who follow
those particular people
online will come
and sample our show
and get a look at our show.
But I think you
have to stay-- you
have to try to stay current
with the zeitgeist of what's
going on, right?
Which is-- I mean, you guys
are doing it every day.
You guys are--
I mean, the changes.
Think of how-- I mean, you were
talking about just six years
ago with flipout phones and--
right?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I mean, it's
changing all the time.
I love living in--
I love technology.
I love living in the future.
So I love embracing change.
And I have a daughter who's
about to graduate college.
And growing up-- her
growing up in the house,
it was great because I always
wanted to know, what are you
listening to?
What are you watching?
What are you guys talking about?
What are the things that you--
you know, when Heelys were in.
Do you remember Heelys, the
shoes with the little wheels?
My daughter had those,
and we traveled a lot.
So she would use those and she
would be zooming all around.
And she loved traveling
because we'd go to airports
and there were all these
long, long hallways where
she could just be like,
you know, launching.
Especially in Chicago, where
you've got those great long--
and she used to do all
kinds of crazy things.
And so then she got me on a
pair and I almost broke my leg.
And they're hard to
use, if you ever--
No, I love staying current.
I think you can't dig
your head in the sand
and just sort of continually
look at putting VHS
cassettes into your machine.
You got to kind of evolve.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Yes, that's good.
Did you know that your
most searched about season
was your season
of internet stars?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Another
fact that I didn't know.
I love another fun fact.
Another fun fact.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Here's another one.
What do you think is
the most watched YouTube
video from "The Amazing Race"?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Ever?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Ever.
PHIL KEOGHAN: It would
be the watermelon video.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yes.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
And that, for those
of you who don't know,
I think it was season 17.
We were in England.
We had the teams
catapult watermelons.
And these watermelons
were on like a giant--
we used like a giant
catapult system going back
to the old medieval times.
That was sort of designed on
one of those old catapults.
Anyway, we had a team, and
they were from a home shopping
network, right?
Am I right?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yes.
Yeah, Brook and Claire.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah, Brook
and Claire, that's right.
So they got the
watermelon, put it
in a little leather pouch
with the big rubber bands,
and they pulled it back
and pulled it back.
She's pulling and pulling and
pulling, pulling, pulling.
And then boom!
She lets it go.
And somehow, the watermelon went
out, and the piece of leather
flipped around the watermelon.
And then with all
that force, boom!
And came right back, hit
her right in the chin.
And you just see her,
like, reel backwards.
And that video went to
like a million views.
CINDY HALVORSEN: 11 million.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, in the
day it went to a million.
It's now 11?
CINDY HALVORSEN:
It's 11 million.
PHIL KEOGHAN: OK,
that's substantial.
CINDY HALVORSEN: The one time
was probably enough for Claire.
11 million is the internet.
PHIL KEOGHAN: And
that was an old video.
Had that happened
today, that would
be like 100-million-view video.
But I mean-- and quite
frankly, we were really lucky
that she didn't get hurt.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yes.
PHIL KEOGHAN: But that's
one of those anomalies
that you just-- you know, made
for good TV, though, didn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
Are you OK?
OK, great.
That was great TV.
Don't do it again.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Keep
going, keep going, yep.
But I'm sure she did
not want that hitting
her face 11 million times.
The slowmo is the best, if you
go back to YouTube and watch
the slowmo.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh,
yeah, you're sick.
You watched that in slow motion.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
It's so fascinating.
The watermelon just--
PHIL KEOGHAN: It is fascinating.
I did watch it in slowmo too.
It's like--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That's awesome.
So the show films over-- each
episode is a couple of days.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah, so
it's 12 shows in 21 days.
Which a lot of people don't
realize, is it's nuts.
I mean, you think about that.
Right now we're on episode 3.
So those teams, those strangers
have known each other about 85
hours.
And people, because we're
spread out week after week,
people assume that, you know,
there's all this downtime.
And I often get people
who say, oh, Phil, you
must just, like, hang out at
the pool and drink pina coladas.
And I'm like, dude,
you have no idea.
I'm trying to race ahead of
these people who are hell
bent on racing ahead of me.
And they're fast.
You get winners like you
around, it gets challenging.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So
what is the best thing
left on the cutting room floor?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, I am going
to tell you this categorically.
If there's anything
that is that good,
there's no way
it's on the floor.
I mean, that would be
like, oh, yeah, well, it
was this great scene where the
watermelon came back and hit
the girl in the face.
We left it on the floor.
No, trust me.
If it's good, it's in the show.
We will find a way to
put it in if it's good.
So no.
Yeah, no.
We're lucky that we have
so many great moments.
And it all starts
with great ideas.
And you know, the great ideas
filter down from the top,
from Bertram and his
vision of what he wants
and then other people injecting
great ideas into the show.
And it's a huge
collaboration, you know,
because it's one thing to
have an idea for something.
It's another thing to
execute it, as we all know.
We've seen so many great
ideas poorly executed.
"Amazing Race" is
a great idea that's
been beautifully executed.
It was originally Elise
Doganieri's idea for a show
because Bertram
challenged her to come up
with a good idea for a show.
And she had been backpacking
in Europe and thought, well--
and I guess there were a few
sparks with her traveling
partner, and maybe she felt that
would make for a good TV show.
And so it started with
the gem of an idea.
But again, at the time
that "Amazing Race"
was being pitched,
there were about four
race-around-the-world-type
shows being pitched.
And interestingly, I
was actually interviewed
for another show that was--
I think it was Fox Family,
which was later ABC Family.
I was in for an
interview for that show
when I heard about "The
Amazing Race" show.
And they're working
title was, you
know, "80 Days Around the
World" or whatever it was.
And so they were pitching
them all at the same time.
But again, the
idea is one thing.
It's the execution.
And so what I'm proud
of with "Amazing Race"
is that I'm really proud
to be a part of a team that
has continued to execute
this great idea very well
and consistently for 17 years.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So let's
talk about the logistics
of the show.
One of the things that really
amazed me when we set off in LA
was just the production
value, right?
So the number of people
traveling with us,
the security, all the producers.
What's one thing
that viewers would
be really interested to know
from behind the scenes, other
than you've mentioned a couple
times the 21 days of filming?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, some
interesting information.
For instance, every team has a
cameraman and a sound person.
The team is never allowed
to leave that sound person.
The sound person
and camera operator
are completely independent.
They have all the
batteries they need.
They have all the tape
stock or recording device
that they need.
They really do operate
like an independent unit
when they're with you, right?
And there's quite
a bond that forms
between the teams and the crew.
Out of fairness, we do swap
up the crews and the teams
so that one team doesn't always
have the same camera crew.
When the teams
book their flights,
they're booking for
four people, you know.
There has to be room for
people to go onto the flight.
Again, just the logistics
of 12 shows in 21 days.
It's less than
two days per show.
We want the teams
to be well fed,
so we do feed them
at the pit stops.
And you know, we want
them to be highly
functioning human beings.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Pit
stops were every two days.
We were not well fed.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Really?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, what--
CINDY HALVORSEN: I,
like, really remember
Jeremy eating someone's
hamburger from the airport
cafeteria.
He just stopped
someone and said,
are you going to finish that?
And he ate their burger.
Because we were starving.
PHIL KEOGHAN: The other
thing you should know
is that "Amazing Race"
is a great diet plan.
So--
CINDY HALVORSEN: It is!
Look how skinny I
was in the race.
PHIL KEOGHAN: If you
want to lose weight,
you can come in at 200
and you'll leave it 100.
Yeah.
OK.
Well, we try to feed them
really well at the pit stops.
CINDY HALVORSEN: At the pit
stops, we get fed really well.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
And then you get to sleep.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Stuff our pockets.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
You get to sleep.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Like six hours before
your next interview
has to start.
PHIL KEOGHAN: OK.
Well, we get to sleep
less than you, actually.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Oh, man, really?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, yeah, as
crew, I mean, yeah, absolutely.
So I always say that the
experience that you guys have
is kind of like doing
interval training,
where you sprint like crazy
and then you stop down
and then you sprint like
crazy and stop down.
So for us, it's just nonstop.
So only three teams go from
the beginning to the end.
We as production,
obviously, we go
from beginning to
end, the whole thing.
And as soon as we're
finished with the teams,
then we're already on to
trying to get to the next place
to start shooting to stay ahead.
And one of the reasons
that I started doing those
live updates that I
do, which I wasn't
doing when you were there.
But one of the reasons
I started doing it was I
was always just trying to
stay ahead of the teams
to explain the challenges.
So I had to go
everywhere they went.
But a lot of times the
teams would turn up,
and then I would have to
get out, get out of the way.
So I was, like, so
frustrated that I
was missing a lot of
explaining to the audience
that I just said, all right,
just roll with the team
running through
and I'll just say,
you know, Ernie and Cindy
are the first to arrive
at this detour.
And what they have
to do is X, Y, and Z.
So that's where those
live events came from.
And then I had one shot to get--
and the audience
loved the idea that I
had one take to get it right.
But you know, there
are times, I mean,
in the history of
"Amazing Race" when
the Globetrotters were on in
season 18, I think it was.
We were in Prague.
Was that-- no, it was 17.
I'm sorry.
We were in Prague.
And I was there in Prague at
the pit stop for about 5 o'clock
for the first team.
I saw the sun set.
I waited all night.
I saw the sun rise,
and the Globetrotters
arrived in the daylight
after I had been on a mat.
And that was all we had was
a mat on a piece of grass
out on the end of a
little island in Prague.
And I was out there
for about 16 hours
or whatever it was total to
wait for them to eliminate them.
But that was not the record.
The record was season 11
when I waited for the Guidos
for 19 hours.
I was at the pit stop
outside in the snow.
CINDY HALVORSEN: You don't get
to go into a warm tent or van
or--
PHIL KEOGHAN: Not in-- no.
There are some situations like
when we were in the Botswana--
we were in the salt
pans in Africa.
And there was no respite.
The only respite you got
from the sun was an umbrella.
And we were out there
for about 12 hours.
So you get cooked.
And there have been
times where I'm still
waiting for the
last team to come in
and the first team has gone
on to the next leg, which just
throws everything into chaos.
So we never shut down.
Like this season, for
instance, is typical
that we won't get to a hotel
for the first six, seven days.
So this season, for
instance, I never got--
we left Los Angeles, we
flew overnight to Panama,
we shot all day, we flew
overnight to Brazil,
overnight to Africa,
we shot all day.
And so we were up to
day six and we still
hadn't been-- none of
us had been to a bed.
So a lot of times I
get home and people
say, Phil, you looked
like crap last night.
I saw the show.
You looked so bad.
And I go, yeah, I know, I know.
And they go, like, you looked
like just like a wreck.
And I'm like, yeah.
So of course, it's just me,
a cameraman, and a sound guy.
I don't have a makeup person
or anyone looking after me.
And occasionally the crew will
forget to tell me, you know,
that my hair is sticking
up on some weird angle.
And I wash my hair on the road
when I don't get to hotels.
So I carry a little thing
of Johnson and Johnson
shampoo, which is very
gentle on the scalp.
I use that when I'm traveling.
So I have crazy photographs
of me having my hair
washed outside the Terracotta
Warriors in China, you know,
or--
yeah.
It's a really, really tough
gig, but it's a great gig.
And it's a gig that
a lot of people, I
don't know if they
really understand.
Then I write the scripts with
one of the producers, Pat,
before I leave.
So then as we're going,
everything is changing.
So I'm having to
write the scripts.
So a lot of times I'm on a plane
and I just want to go to sleep,
but I'm having to
rewrite scripts.
Or the last show isn't
written before we take off,
and then I'm
exhausted, and then I'm
writing that on the last
flight in to the end city.
Like what happened this time.
So I'm not complaining, by
the way, because I love it.
I'm just saying that
that is the gig.
It's not 70 degrees
in an LA studio
doing a show where people sing.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So I shouldn't
complain about our eating
every two days because
you didn't eat for six?
PHIL KEOGHAN: No, because
it's-- no, no, no, no.
I'm not saying--
I'm not comparing it that way
because I think it's tough.
I think it's just a tough gig.
It's tough for the racers.
It's way tougher
than people realize.
But I also think that a
lot of people who are not--
who haven't been out, they
don't understand just also
how hard it is for the crew.
I mean, you think about the crew
running around after you guys
and what they do.
It's pretty crazy.
You getting a shot there, Ernie?
ERNIE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah, just--
[LAUGHTER]
There you go.
All right.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So if you
could host any other show,
what show would you host?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Uh.
I like my show.
I like this show I do.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Not
even like the Emmys
or "The Bachelor," all
your pretty ladies now?
PHIL KEOGHAN: That's the
last show I'd want to host.
[LAUGHTER]
I find it so depressing.
Oh, god.
I just watch what some people
do and I just think, oh, no,
please don't.
Don't put that on.
I find it-- like, I really
feel myself cringing for them.
I'm just, oh, no, don't
do that, no, don't.
No, I think maybe
shows that I really--
reality shows that
I really like.
I love-- has anybody seen
"Chef's Table" at all?
Beautifully shot,
beautiful show.
I love Anthony
Bourdain, you know.
Some people, you
know, really love him.
Some people don't get him.
But I like him, and
I like that show.
I find it fascinating.
Ironically, every
time he does anything
to do with food and
cooking, I can't watch.
I don't like it
because my pet peeve
is watching people eat on TV.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
But you make us eat.
Well, we didn't eat in
our season, thankfully.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, that's
when it's a challenge.
But the thing I hate
more than anything
is when people eat on TV
and then they do the whole--
oh, that's good.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like, no.
And what I love
about "Chef's Table"
is they don't--
if you look at it,
they don't show people eating.
It's all about the story behind
the food, behind the person,
and the passion for the food.
And they prepare the food
and they show the food,
but they don't do the
gratuitous, like, people just
eating food.
So anyway, why am I
even talking about this?
Because I would never be
able to do a show about food
because I just love eating
food, not on camera.
And I don't know how to cook.
But I think those sort
of shows, I love that.
I love-- you know, if you're
talking about nonfiction,
I love any documentary.
Really fascinated with
real-life stories.
I love "60 Minutes."
It's like my staple.
If I was stuck on an island
and I had to watch one show,
I'd probably watch that because
you're going to see Lady Gaga
on one end and then you're going
to see some really heavy piece
about really understanding
what's going on in Iraq
or where they--
you're always seeing--
I love-- I love real stuff.
That's why I think I find it
hard to watch, like, "Bachelor"
because it's just
like, oh, no, just
go meet some people
in real life.
Don't do that to yourself.
It's OK.
You don't need a rose.
[LAUGHTER]
CINDY HALVORSEN: Well,
speaking of documentaries,
I do want to take a moment
to share the preview
clip of your movie tonight.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, thank you.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So
why don't we roll that?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING]
[PANTING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This is a story about
courageous underdogs,
the first English-speaking
team to compete in the Tour de
France.
I don't know why people want
to take on these challenges,
but I really believe
that it's only
by pushing yourself to
the borders of suffering
and discomfort that you
really find out who you are.
This is an insane idea.
But what about if
you actually go back
and you retrace every mile?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the dream team--
my buddy Ben, highway
patrol officer Greg,
and ace shooter Scott.
- These races were meant to
be like the last man standing.
- I don't think you know what
you're letting yourself in for.
And if you did,
you wouldn't do it.
- I'm going to try to make this
ride as authentic as I possibly
can.
My bike feels like
it's got a [INAUDIBLE].
- It's not like that.
You'll kill yourself.
[TRUCK HORN BLOWING]
- To ride a 1928 bike
along the same roads
while sticking to
the same schedule?
Is that even possible?
- This way or this way?
- No, [SPEAKING FRENCH]
- OK, this way?
- Yes.
- [SPEAKING FRENCH]
- Are we going that way?
- Yes.
- OK, let's turn around.
This way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Climbing 20,000
feet in one day.
That's insane.
There are huge stretches of
time that I don't remember.
- Beyond bru-- brutal.
Beyond brutal.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Man, do I have some
respect for the riders who
rode in 1928.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The most challenging
parts are yet to come.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
CINDY HALVORSEN: Awesome.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
It was a long ride.
[APPLAUSE]
CINDY HALVORSEN: So tell us
a little bit about the movie.
Where did you get the
inspiration to do this movie?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Well, I love
stories about underdogs.
I think that's why I always
root for the underdogs
on "Amazing Race."
I just find-- it's
like the Cubs, right?
It's like that story,
that story of people
doing something that
is so well deserved
after so much hard work.
And I always read
books about underdogs,
like the guy who came up with
the clock that could keep time
for Captain Cook when he was
traveling over the oceans
to be able to map the world out.
They needed to have Greenwich
Mean Time on the ship,
and they needed to
have a clock that
would withstand the rigors
of being at sea on a ship.
And this one guy who
was a carpenter, who
wasn't a scientist,
spent his lifetime
making five clocks
before he finally
came up with a clock
that could keep time.
And all the scientists couldn't
believe that a carpenter
came up with the solution.
So I always love those
kinds of stories.
And I found a book about the
first English-speaking team
to ride in the Tour
de France, which
happened to be the tour
with the highest attrition
rate of any tour in history.
And I thought, wow.
How do I not know this story?
I love the Tour de France.
I'm from New Zealand.
There's one New Zealander
and three Australians.
So I decided I would
tell the story,
bring it to life somehow
in a documentary.
And of course, all
those riders are
all gone, and all the people
who remember those riders
and remember that
time, they're all gone.
And so I thought,
rather than telling
the story in a traditional
documentary style
where I would be on
the outside and show
a bunch of archival
footage and tell the story,
researching and being more
of a spectator, if you like.
If I put myself in the story
and I rode a 1928 Tour de France
bike that weighs twice
as much as a modern bike,
that has no gears, I went
over every single road,
I went to every--
over every single--
to every single town and
over all the mountains,
I could have a
different perspective.
And we could juxtapose 1928 with
when we rode it in modern times
and try to bring
the story to life.
And it's one of the more
stupid things I've ever done,
but it's--
because you cannot
take on a physical--
we were riding an average
of 150 miles a day.
We had seven stages
over 200 miles.
We had one day that took
us 23 and 1/2 hours.
And the idea of trying to
take on a physical challenge
like that while you're making a
movie is just not a good idea.
However, I mentioned before
that I love technology.
I love new technology.
Sony heard that I was
going to do this--
have a good friend at Sony--
and they said,
listen, would you like
to try out our brand-new F55
4K camera on your documentary?
And no documentary had
ever been shot in 4K
with an F55 camera
at that point.
So I said, absolutely.
And then Angenieux, which is
a French lens company that
make beautiful
lenses, they loaned us
$400,000 worth of beautiful
French fast lenses.
Really, for any of you who
know about photography,
super fast lenses that allow
you to shoot in really low light
conditions.
So we had this
incredible technology.
And then one of our--
one of my best friends who
I've known for 30 years, way
before "Amazing
Race" but he ended up
working on "Amazing Race"--
he's this incredible shooter.
When I rode across America
to raise money for MS
a few years ago, he sat
on a motorbike backwards
for 3,500 miles.
And I called him up and
I said, hey, Scott, I've
got a great idea.
We're going to go around France.
We're going to retrace
the 1928 Tour de France.
How would you feel
about shooting that?
And he goes, do I have to
sit on a motorbike backwards
to shoot that?
And I went, yes.
And he went, OK, I'm in.
So he's seen America
backwards, and he's
seen all of France backwards.
And so we shot this film.
And we couldn't get funding
in the beginning for it,
so it's all self-funded.
It took five years to make.
And the Google connection
here with the film,
if you saw in the trailer where
we come zooming in out of space
and we go into the
Arc de Triomphe
and into the Champs-Elysees.
So Craig Manning,
who works in your--
worked for Google in
New York and now is
working on another project
in conjunction with Google--
I called him up.
He's a fellow New Zealander.
And I said, listen.
I'm using Google right now
to retrace the 1928 Tour
de France.
And I'd love to use one
of your maps to, like,
fly in to the Arc de Triomphe.
Can you help me?
So he hooked me up with
some guys in Boulder,
where my daughter
is at university.
So I went to the Google
office in Boulder.
And I worked with a guy there.
And then there's two maps in the
film that you'll actually see.
And we rendered them all
to be able to match 4K
so the quality is really good.
The other Google connection
is, I decided that I really
needed to have aerials of France
in order to bring this to life.
And so I went on Google Maps
and I'm starting to, like,
fly around on Google Maps.
And what I realized was
that I could actually fly--
because I didn't have
a whole bunch of money
to spend on helicopter time--
I could fly at a certain
speed from point A to point B
and save KMZ files of
each of the plot points
and work out where I wanted
to shoot the Col d'Aubisque.
I wanted to be 500
feet off the ground.
I want to be in
this position right
here to get the mountains
at that level and the Col
d'Aubisque and see the road.
And so I saved all
these KMZ files.
Then I gave all of those
files to the pilot.
I said-- and then I made
a video of the route.
And then I put it all
in electronic form,
give it all to him.
He pulled it up on his computer.
We got the helicopter
out of Spain
to fly across the
Pyrenees into France.
And he literally just
followed the KMZ files
that I made in Google Maps.
And then he knew exactly--
like, I didn't have to explain
to him, go a little lower.
Go a little to the right.
He had the exact spot.
So I did all of
that in Google Maps
before we got up in the
air and we're burning
expensive helicopter fuel.
So saved me a tremendous amount.
And then just recently
I did a project
for the Smithsonian
Channel, which
is all aerials of New Zealand,
like, every single shot,
an aerial shot of New Zealand.
And I did exactly
the same thing.
And I went and I was able to see
exactly where and how to do it.
And it's all because
of that technology,
which is such a great
tool now for filmmakers.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That's great.
PHIL KEOGHAN: So thank you.
I don't know, are there any
Google Maps people in here?
No?
CINDY HALVORSEN: We
all use them, probably.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
It's great, though, right?
I mean, how amazing.
CINDY HALVORSEN: We are going to
invite some of the other racers
up here and do a
quick Q&A with them,
and then we will be open for
questions from the audience.
So Ernie, do you want to come?
Ernie, if you guys
don't know, this
is my husband from season 19.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
And Idries we have
from season 22, who
raced with his twin brother.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: I did.
CINDY HALVORSEN: And then
we've got Kurt from season 28.
He was on the internet
all-star season with Brodie.
They play Frisbee.
KURT GIBSON: Yeah.
CINDY HALVORSEN: So we're going
to do a lightning round of Q&A.
Do you want to--
PHIL KEOGHAN: Sure.
CINDY HALVORSEN: --now
ask us the questions?
PHIL KEOGHAN: All right.
Do you want all of you to
answer every single question?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yes.
And we're going to go speedy.
PHIL KEOGHAN: OK.
OK.
Favorite place that you
went to on "Amazing Race"?
KURT GIBSON: Chamonix, France.
Got [INAUDIBLE].
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Oh,
we were in Jakarta.
Jakarta was probably my
favorite, in that cave.
CINDY HALVORSEN: No,
the cave was not.
It was scary.
ERNIE HALVORSEN:
It wasn't scary.
CINDY HALVORSEN: It was scary.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Not
your favorite place?
CINDY HALVORSEN: It was
a massive grave site, no?
ERNIE HALVORSEN: But
that was awesome.
CINDY HALVORSEN: That
place in Indonesia?
[LAUGHTER]
PHIL KEOGHAN: I don't even want
to start an argument with you.
This is great TV.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Oh,
it's good [INAUDIBLE].
What about you?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
I guess Bora Bora.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Bora Bora?
OK.
Well, how cool was that, right?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
Oh, that was phenomenal.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Although
the search in the sand.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
That was hell on earth.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: I'm sorry.
That was hell on earth.
PHIL KEOGHAN: OK.
Biggest fear going
into "Amazing Race."
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: Losing.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
CINDY HALVORSEN:
And how'd you do?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: We lost.
[LAUGHTER]
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah, It's
a lot tougher than people
think, though, right?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: It is.
Oh, my god.
You know, when you watch it
on TV, like, do this, do that.
It looks like it's so easy.
When you're there, it's
like, this is crazy.
This is so hard.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
I know, it happens so quick.
What about you, biggest fear?
Did you have any fears?
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Probably what
my friends thought about me.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
And what do your friends
think about you now?
Have they said?
ERNIE HALVORSEN:
They've given up on me.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, they give up.
What about you?
KURT GIBSON: I
think it's probably
looking really
bad on television,
looking really dumb.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, yeah?
KURT GIBSON: Sometimes,
you know, I mean,
I kind of have this
brace on right now,
so I know I kind
of look dumb but--
PHIL KEOGHAN: You should explain
what happened to you, Kurt.
KURT GIBSON: I was
in the Philippines
and on this island
called Bellarocca.
And me and my buddy
thought it was a good idea
to go to this aerial point,
have a cool beach day, whatever.
And there's these cliffs
there and there's like a 5--
PHIL KEOGHAN: And you
wanted to jump off it.
KURT GIBSON: --8- ,
and 15-meter dive.
No, but the funny
thing was my buddy
was trying to get me to
go off the 15-meter dive.
And I'm like, no.
I don't want to get hurt.
You can do that but
I'm not doing that.
So I was going off the middle
one with all the kids and all,
like, the parents and stuff.
And my fourth jump I land
and my arm goes like this,
and I tore my pec.
So lovely.
That's a lovely story.
PHIL KEOGHAN: And you're going
to be like that for six weeks,
right?
Which is not good
if you play Frisbee.
KURT GIBSON: No.
PHIL KEOGHAN: No.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Did you have
a fear going into the race?
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Crying, which that
broke in the first
episode, so I don't know.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Crying
is like eating on TV.
It can be a good look sometimes.
The most useful thing
that you guys packed.
What would you say?
Frisbee?
KURT GIBSON: No, we lost
that on the first cab ride
at the airport.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Did you really?
KURT GIBSON: We
wanted to bring it.
We had these grand
plans of, like,
throwing it to the mat when
we finished, but we lost it.
We don't know what
happened to it.
No.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Probably
under clean underwear.
But I would say on the race, I
learned about this new, like,
stick that they use, what
that thing was called?
The--
PHIL KEOGHAN: The stink stick?
ERNIE HALVORSEN: It's kind of
like a stink stick, you know.
They rubbed it in areas
to make it nice and--
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, oh.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: Wait, what?
PHIL KEOGHAN: No,
you're talking about--
ERNIE HALVORSEN: You know
what I'm talking about?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah, no, I know
what you're talking about.
Yeah, no, it's--
AUDIENCE: Deodorant?
[LAUGHTER]
ERNIE HALVORSEN:
It's like deodorant,
but it's like a non-cake stick.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah, no, no.
It stops chafing.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
And--
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Body.
Body Glide.
But they called it
something different.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
There's a name.
I'll tell you later.
I think it's a little rough.
ERNIE HALVORSEN:
Don't say it here.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Might be rough.
I think I probably
shouldn't say it.
But it's just-- needless
to say, the name of it
involves a certain
part of the anatomy.
And it's actually a legit
name that you can buy.
If you googled it and you
put the name of an anatomy
and then put cream,
it'll come up.
So what about you with--
CINDY HALVORSEN: Idries.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
No, that's all right.
Actually, it sounds strange,
but, like, a compression shirt.
It kept, like, all the sweat
from actually going places.
It's absorb-- and I'm
actually wearing one now.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Lot of
hygiene things, right?
I guess, you know,
you miss that, right?
KURT GIBSON: Frisbee's
good for hygiene too.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah,
toothbrush for sure.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Toothbrush.
CINDY HALVORSEN: I will
say the least useful thing
we packed was a compass because
we didn't know how to read it.
So what a waste of
space in our bag.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah,
compass, really?
CINDY HALVORSEN:
We got really lost.
PHIL KEOGHAN: What
talent would you
have liked to have had
to help you on the race
that you maybe didn't have?
Is there any talent?
ERNIE HALVORSEN: I
think it was language.
KURT GIBSON: Language.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: I think
language is the easiest thing.
KURT GIBSON: Yeah.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: You
know, if I could speak it.
We tried to learn
Russian, but that's tough.
It didn't really work.
Yeah.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I know a
guy who knows a guy who
could teach you Russian.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Let's do it.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: Google him.
PHIL KEOGHAN: What about you?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
Swimming, obviously.
Obviously I'm not
a good swimmer,
and that's why we lost.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah, that was
challenging, though, right?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
It was challenging.
It was--
PHIL KEOGHAN: But
when you filled out
the form to come onto
the show, did they
ask you if you could swim?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: They did.
I can swim, but I'm
not a good swimmer.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Right.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: When
they put you in the ocean,
you're kind of like,
I'm going to die.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
I get that.
I mean, it's a fear
for some people.
You know, they get in the ocean.
I was just talking to
a guy who didn't learn
how to swim until he was 36.
And he said it was the
biggest thing in his life
to try to learn how to do that.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: Yeah.
It's still kind of a--
it's a big thing for me.
I have my kids in swimming
because, you know, I'm like--
PHIL KEOGHAN: You should
just keep going at it.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
I'm going to.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Don't give up.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
I'm going to.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Don't give up.
What about you?
KURT GIBSON: I think
arts and crafts.
I know it sounds
silly, but we basically
got eliminated because
we got towards the back
when I had to tie those
little tiny, like, salt
bags and my fingers couldn't
really get around it.
And then Brodie building a
kite really put us far back.
So if we could just kind
of build these things.
PHIL KEOGHAN: But
you're not-- let's
be honest-- you're
not going to go out
and do macrame class,
you know what I mean?
KURT GIBSON: Hey, for
a million dollars?
PHIL KEOGHAN: No,
but I mean now.
It's not like you're
rushing out to go do--
KURT GIBSON: Oh, no, now, no.
No.
PHIL KEOGHAN: You're
not doing arts and--
KURT GIBSON: No, no, no.
PHIL KEOGHAN: With
you, anything?
Was there--
CINDY HALVORSEN: I
think the only thing is
I wish I was a little taller.
PHIL KEOGHAN: How
would that have helped?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Everyone
was so tall in the race
and they could run faster
because their legs were longer.
They could climb
those ladders faster
because their arms were longer.
It really was an inhibitor.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Do
you think we should
standardize the height
for all the amazing races
to make it fair?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Hm.
It might be a good one.
PHIL KEOGHAN: But you won.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Right?
She still won.
[LAUGHTER]
PHIL KEOGHAN: The tall
people are probably saying,
you know, I wish I was shorter.
All right, what surprised you
most once you were on the show?
Like, what was the one thing
that really surprised you?
CINDY HALVORSEN: The logistics.
I feel like the moment we hit
that first mat and everything
just popped up.
It was like bounce
boards, cameras.
Everyone scooped on in.
That was really amazing.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Right.
But the stuff you don't
see behind the cameras.
Was there something
that surprised you?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
For me, it was the pace.
I mean, you know, it
was just going so fast.
PHIL KEOGHAN: It's relentless.
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN:
Just relentless.
I was like, wow, this is crazy.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Yeah,
it was definitely more
about the production,
going out there and just--
you were just left on your own.
Like, I thought there was
going to be more, like,
scripted stuff.
There's going to be more like,
here's what you're going to do.
Blah, blah, blah.
PHIL KEOGHAN: All right.
Here's a great dramatic moment.
What I want you to see--
ERNIE HALVORSEN:
They just drop you!
And I'm like, OK,
what do I do now?
Cindy, what do we do?
PHIL KEOGHAN: You guys
have all been on the show.
And you will attest to the fact
that we really pride ourselves
in trying to make the race
as authentic as possible.
You hear people say,
oh, was that fake?
Was that scripted?
Was that set up and whatever?
No.
And we pride ourselves in,
you guys are like our writers.
You write the content,
meaning whatever you do
becomes the script, the
transcript of the show, right?
So we set up the circumstances,
and we throw you out there
to go do it.
And how you react
to that stimulus
is what creates the show.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: I just
wasn't expecting that, so.
PHIL KEOGHAN: You
know there are shows--
there are shows that do
manipulate and, like,
you know--
we really pride
ourselves in trying
to make a fair race as
much as possible, you know?
And man, one of the things I get
the most from fans is they'll
say, why didn't you say
something to that teen?
Like when the Twinnies moved
the money, do you remember?
IDRIES ABDUR-RAHMAN: Um-hm.
PHIL KEOGHAN: And there was
a season where the Twinnies--
CINDY HALVORSEN: Oh, yeah.
PHIL KEOGHAN: And I didn't know.
Like, I don't see in real time
what the audience is seeing.
But they see this happen,
and then they see me.
And they think that somehow
I'm meant to know, like,
every little detail.
I haven't seen it.
It's all just raw
footage at that point.
So it's always, I have
to explain to them, well,
hold on a second.
At the point when I was
talking to them, first of all,
I didn't know.
But you've seen way more about
what just happened on that leg
than I have at that point.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Right.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Like later,
yeah, I catch up but--
KURT GIBSON: I think that's part
of what makes the show so fun
to watch too is, I mean, one
of our episodes in Chamonix,
our favorite, we had to go zip
line to get that first clue.
And so it's not really,
like, clear directions,
but they're kind of like,
hey, you got to go do that.
So Brodie starts going over
the ledge to go get hooked up.
And he's like, all right,
what do I need to do?
And the guy's like, no, no, no.
Just one of you.
And so Brodie kind of like looks
and is like, Kurt, you do this.
I'm going back over, right?
So it's just like,
we're dreading
that moment, like, wait.
I don't want to do that.
You do that, you know?
But just those kind of
moments make it fun.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: The vagueness.
You're like, you're
not sure if you're
doing the right thing exactly.
You're like, is this--
PHIL KEOGHAN: But when you
think about the circumstances
that you guys all end up in,
right, it takes a while when
you get back to kind of process,
oh, my god, we were in Chamonix
and we were about to
leap off a mountain.
And it all, for me, it
takes me about two weeks
to, like, process
everything that's happened.
Because it's all happening
so fast and there's so much.
So much so quickly.
KURT GIBSON: And even
in the downtime too,
you're like thinking
about the next leg.
You're just like,
downtime, but you're
getting ready to stress
for the next 24 hours.
PHIL KEOGHAN: And then
we're interviewing
you guys and [INAUDIBLE].
CINDY HALVORSEN:
Well, and we tore
through every hotel room
looking for any clue
about the next day.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Really?
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah,
we showed up one day.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: You guys pulled
the TVs out of every room.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Yeah.
Did you know that, the
TVs are not in the rooms?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah,
no, I know that.
But you went with four TVs?
ERNIE HALVORSEN: You
did that on purpose.
CINDY HALVORSEN: No, we were
looking for any information.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: They
were all in Phil's room.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Don't make me
take that million dollars
back when you tell me--
CINDY HALVORSEN: We
didn't break any rules.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I mean, that's
going to disqualify you.
CINDY HALVORSEN: We
didn't break any rules.
PHIL KEOGHAN: We had this
question come up here
like that.
CINDY HALVORSEN: OK, so this
is an audience question.
What's the scariest
moment for you
in "The Amazing Race" history?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Is this
from somebody here,
or is that someone--
you could just talk to me.
KURT GIBSON: Wow,
this is awesome.
PHIL KEOGHAN: I mean, come on.
I love technology, but,
dude, you can talk to me.
CHARLES: No, I'm happy to.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah,
what's our name?
KURT GIBSON: No,
that was awesome.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Charles.
OK, Charles is in
the audience here.
Charles, I love how
you use technology.
CHARLES: I didn't know how
crowded it would get in here.
PHIL KEOGHAN: OK.
So you're saying, yeah,
what's the scariest moment
in "The Amazing Race" history?
CHARLES: Yeah, mine
was the watermelon one
that you talked about.
But I don't know if there was
any other ones that you thought
were, like, pretty terrible.
PHIL KEOGHAN: You know, I think
a lot of what the teams do
is perceived danger, you know.
All the challenges that they do.
We're so ridiculous
about making sure
that they're run stringently
and that the teams are safe.
The part I worry about
the most is when a car--
they get in a car, in a taxi,
and the car is driving fast.
And maybe the teams ask
the driver to slow down.
We've had cars, accidents
on the show before.
And those are the calls
you don't want to get.
When you get a call
and we find out a team
has been in an accident.
And Chip and Reichen
rolled a car in season 4.
In season 1 we had
a team go over.
I'm trying to think
of who was in the car.
I think it was the
Guidos might have been.
There was an accident.
So yeah, that's the
scariest thing for me.
I worry about them the
most when, like you said,
when you guys are on your own.
Even little things like
just crossing the road.
Like, sometimes they'll
be in a crazy place,
they might be in
India, and they're
in a really busy
intersection, and that's
where things can go wrong.
Because they're out of
our control, you know.
And that's the
part I worry about.
For me, personal
scary moment was--
not scary, but kind of surreal
moment-- was I was in Ukraine
and we flew in in the
middle of the night.
And I had a New
Zealand passport.
And I was told I
didn't need a visa,
but for whatever reason this
guy thought I did need a visa.
So I was separated
from everybody.
And the crew-- the
teams, sorry, were
going to be arriving
the next morning,
so I had a little bit
of a head start on them.
So I was going to
be getting up early
to go shoot all the
introductions to the challenges
before the teams came in.
And we were expecting
the first team
to arrive at the mat at
10 o'clock in the morning.
That was the estimated time.
And anyway, they pulled me away.
It was 1 o'clock
something in the morning.
And they took me to this little
room and then left me there.
And they didn't speak English.
And I was like, OK.
So I waited there
and waited there.
And I had a sense that there was
something going on in the room
but I wasn't really sure.
And there was light
only at one end.
And it smelt like people in
there, but I wasn't sure.
And there were
four plastic seats
with the handles that go over
like that, kind of like this.
So I stayed, waited
there all night.
And I didn't have
phone service so I
didn't know what was going on.
And I thought, oh, I'm
going to try to sleep.
So I put my body through
the plastic handles and I
lay along the plastic seats.
And then the next morning
someone woke me up.
And I looked and I realized
I was trapped in the seat.
And then I looked back
and then I saw the room.
There was all this light
and there were a whole bunch
of people in there.
And I had been
asleep and I didn't
realize that there were
like 50 people in the room.
And then the guy says, you know,
(RUSSIAN ACCENT) come with me.
So I got up and I left.
And a woman who worked with
the American government,
was a huge "Amazing Race" fan
and had stayed up all night
to get me the appropriate
visa that I needed.
So I got put into a room, got a
stamp, ran out of the airport,
jumped in a car.
Didn't have time to shoot
any of the standups that
introduced the challenges,
went straight to the mat.
Got to the mat, and the
first team came in 10 minutes
after I arrived at the mat.
Yeah, it was not scary.
It was just sort
of like, all right.
I hope everything's OK.
I hope Mr. Putin is not coming
to take over Ukraine right now.
CINDY HALVORSEN: OK.
We've got one--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks for stopping by.
"The Amazing Race" is
syndicated in other markets.
There's an international
version of the show.
Of course, without Phil
so not quite as cool.
But is there any coordination
between the various versions,
like a list of places to go that
you'd look at where "Amazing
Race France" went or "Amazing
Race Japan" or something
like that?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah,
so the franchise
has been very popular
around the world.
The show plays--
"The Amazing Race" US version,
plays in 140 countries,
I believe, around the world.
And then the show's been
copied in Australia and Canada,
in Israel, South America,
a few different places.
And they use all
the same graphics.
They use a lot of
the same ideas.
They've repeated a lot
of the same challenges.
And then they've also come up
with some of their own as well.
So it's part of the
format of "Amazing Race."
There isn't like a
direct connection
between one and the other.
But absolutely, it's
all based on that format
of "Amazing Race."
Yeah.
And I like your fish hook.
Is it from Hawaii
or from New Zealand?
AUDIENCE: It's New Zealand.
It's the first thing I
bought when I got there.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Oh, nice.
OK.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Is that where
you get all of your necklaces?
PHIL KEOGHAN: Yeah.
So forever-- yeah.
It's a New Zealand
Maori fish hook.
The Maori are the indigenous
people of New Zealand.
And the way they do
their fish hooks--
I seem to be talking
a lot about fishing.
Not even a fishermen.
But anyway, the fish hook, they
put bait over the fish hook
and then the fish swallows
the whole fish hook,
swallows it whole, and
then it gets stuck.
And the Maori people wear them.
And if you wear a
greenstone one--
actually, you're
not meant to buy it.
You're meant to be given it.
And I've always worn one.
It's meant to give
you safety over water.
So I've always worn
it on "The Race."
Thank you for hosting.
You did a great job.
CINDY HALVORSEN: Thanks.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Thank you,
Google, for having me and--
CINDY HALVORSEN: Thank you.
PHIL KEOGHAN: Thank you, guys.
ERNIE HALVORSEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]